char dr. Tara Narula joins us now from
her home in New York City good morning
to you Tara really good to see you good
morning again we are all craving good
always nice to see you we are all
craving some kind of positive news and
it looks like maybe we're seeing it here
in New York where they say there are
reports of a leveling off of
hospitalization hospital hospitalization
and deaths in the city so what exactly
does that mean and what happens after an
area starts to peak well you heard the
vice president his words that this is
going to be a week of heartache and hope
and I think that's how we're all feeling
here we're certainly seeing this
leveling off of ICU admissions
hospitalizations intubations all of
which is very encouraging whether we are
at the peak or about to be at the peak
it's it's all good sign however it
should not be taken as a sign to let up
on those mitigation and social
distancing efforts those are exactly
what have gotten us to this point and
dr. Fauci and dr. Brooks yesterday being
very clear and saying if we continue
with those aggressive mitigation efforts
we may not reach those estimates of a
hundred thousand deaths in the United
States that the models have predicted so
this is a time for Americans to
understand that you know hopefully we're
moving in the right direction in New
York it's too early to claim victory but
we do need to keep up those hard efforts
at social distancing yeah Governor Cuomo
very clear about that you heard in
David's piece he's now talking about
thousand-dollar fines and he said now is
not the time to let up you look outside
in Central Park people are sort of
getting closer together because of the
weather is warming up now the White
House Task Force is offering new
guidelines for social distancing what
does that mean what are they well well
it means that we need to continue to
make that effort to stay six feet away
that if you're going to leave your home
as dr. Burke said to go grocery shopping
or to the pharmacy you maybe want to
send one person instead of the whole
family going and try to limit the number
of times that you're outside of the
house
other people if you do venture out as
the weather gets nicer you want to try
to do it at off-peak times or in areas
like your backyard or in large patches
of Central Park where we're bringing our
kids to get a little bit of exercise
every day we are not around other people
so again important to keep that in mind
you don't want to be congregating in big
groups CDC has a new report on the
effects that the corona virus has on
children can you give us some
information on that well this was really
the first CDC report to look solely at
children in the United States they
looked from February to April at over a
hundred thousand cases in the United
States and they found that less than 2%
of those were in a pediatric population
the median age affected was about 11 and
in fact similar to the data in China
there were less hospitalizations in
children children did have fever cough
and shortness of breath but to a lesser
extent than in the adult population so
important to stress that while we see
kids being hit less hard they can still
be affected they are still
hospitalizations and in fact there were
three deaths and children that are being
investigated as possibly related to
Kovan 19 and can we talk about
treatments for just a second are we any
clearer on what treatments actually work
on this on this disease on this virus
well there's no there's no question that
therapeutics are going to be a big part
of turning the tide and when you look at
what the main frontrunners are it is the
antiviral drugs things like REM death
severe which we should have more data
about this month drugs like
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine that
we've spoken extensively about and then
the antibody class of drugs so this is
similar to what we've discussed in terms
of taking plasma from people who've been
affected and giving it to others but we
would bioengineer these antibodies tarah
thank you